hello again
we are Live on YouTube for the second
episode of positive Cloud Essentials my
name is Alex Chisholm I'm part of their
positive Cloud here at positive PPC
where we build tools that make it easier
for you and your teams to do R and
python work and then share that workout
more broadly
last month in episode one we did a crash
course on getting started in posit cloud
and this time I wanted to go a bit a
little bit deeper on the features and
functionality that can help you manage
data projects specifically when working
in these shared spaces on positive cloud
and as we discussed last time positive
cloud is really designed around this
notion of a space
from within a space you can start new
projects either our studio or Jupiter
notebooks at the moment we also have a
new functionality that will tease a
little bit later called project
templates
from these projects or from auth
positive clouds like like a vs code on
your desktop or our studio ID somewhere
else you can publish outputs now to that
space including Dynamic applications as
well as static documents like quarto or
our markdown
another feature we added this year was
Data connections where we make it easier
for you to save the credentials
associated with various database
connections we have the professional
drivers behind the scenes here that
enable you to save these and then pass
them into projects to be used both in
terms of analysis and Publishing
and then finally you can bring people in
control what they see and do and then
monitor what people are doing based upon
that engagement with your content
so this was the the simple view that we
provided last month in reality if you've
been in positive Cloud before you
probably noticed when you start you go
into what's known as this this your
workspace and it's a little bit less
feature packed than a shared space that
we were talking about before
so here's a comparison between your
workspace which we'll take a look at in
a few moments and a shared space in both
of these environments you can create
projects you can publish outputs you can
see what's being done and you can manage
a little bit in terms of filtering and
narrowing into what specific piece of
content you might be interested in
you can also from either of these spaces
use the included pre-configured
templates that are now available from
Baza Cloud to get started faster
on the
shared space side you're going to notice
a bunch more functionality that picks up
what we talked about in the previous
slide so here you can do things with
member management you can have those
data connections you can organize things
into into lists you can create custom
templates so there's a lot more going on
within a shared space and typically when
we're working with organizations who are
bringing on multiple collaborators
either in terms of doing data science
work in a collaborative way or sharing
out different pieces of of outputs like
an application or a dashboard or a
document you're going to have the
ability to set these up more easily
within a shared space
all of these things on the bottom I
think really
project management and what I want to do
today is talk through kind of a demo use
case that focuses on a freelancer or a
Consulting Group and then thinking of
where the work fits into how we've
designed posit cloud from this space's
perspective
so the first thing that is really nice
especially now when you can publish all
types of outputs to positive Cloud
directly you know in the Consulting
workflow typically either you you're
working with one company or a company is
put out maybe an RFP a request for a
proposal you're going out and saying hey
I'm really good at this stuff you should
consider me to do this project for you
it helps a lot whether you're an
individual or a team to have a space
where you can show off the type of work
that you are accustomed uh to doing so
you can use Plaza Cloud to be that kind
of portfolio place to show off and
hopefully win the contract
if you win the opportunity to continue
with a client you can then set up
another dedicated shared space so all
those things we looked at a few moments
ago but within one dedicated environment
that you can use for the entirety of
that project
from which you can invite people who are
going to help you out doing the data
work on this you can ultimately bring in
the client at the end of this to see uh
to see either the outputs or the data
projects themselves in some cases
and then at the end for peace of mind on
that client side it's quite easy for you
to delete the entire project and the
entire space if you wanted to and maybe
you're able to take some of the outputs
that you worked on make them Anonymous
or generalizable and then move those
back into your sample gallery for the
next time that you're going through this
process
so today I'm going to jump into the tool
in just a few seconds we're going to
look at it from two perspectives one is
going to be the the lead consultant or
the project manager at Allegro LLC a
small Consulting Group focused on
marketing analytics for the Performing
Arts industry
so we're going to see how positive Cloud
might be used from their point of view
and then we're also going to see the
other side the client side so Allegro
went out they responded to an RFP from
the Bartok Music Festival they're hoping
to win this proposal that they put
together so they can do work together to
help the music festival increase sales
for the upcoming season
so with that as a primer or as a
starting point we're going to jump over
now and move into posit cloud
for those of you who already have an
account here's where you would just log
in right if you don't have an account
yet you can click on get started
go through and find out about the free
plan that we offer and you can sign up
easily in a variety of ways I have an
account so I'm just going to go ahead
and log in and I'll do it through
through Google in this case
foreign
so the first the thing that I want to
think through and this is the again the
perspective from this lead consultant at
Allegro is trying to use previous work
to get more work right to show people
what you're capable of so that you can
do something similar for their
organization
and I've got a space set up already
called Allegro sample work
and there are only four pieces of of
content here but we'll do a few things
to get this ready to turn into that
portfolio that we're going to be able to
share uh with potential clients
there are a lot of options up here and
we're not going to have time today to
talk through everything but let's just
start on the far right here with about
so this gives you the opportunity to in
addition to you could change the name of
the space overall you could also put in
a little blurb about what this space is
for
so we can we can tell people you know
welcome you know here's what we've done
in the in the past
um and we're going to be able to use
this space to show off some of the
applications some of the reports that
we've done before if you have questions
you know there's a way to reach out to
us so this is once we prep this space in
a way that'll be good for someone who
just wants to view your content they'll
have some guiding and guidance point to
to get started with
if I go back to content you know we can
take a quick look at these the the
existing content that's in this space
and you can look at the metadata here
and tell what everything is so we have a
quarter document
we've got an rstudio project that is on
on ticket attribution uh modeling we
have a shiny application looking at lead
funnels
and we have a streamlit app talking
about customer segmentation so these are
all generalizable things maybe that
Allegro LLC has done in the past that
they want to demonstrate to a new uh
client
um their capabilities
so I can click on you know any one of
these and see you know this is something
that has been created on posit cloud and
published to posit cloud and it's a
quarter report in this case just an
example of having an industry Trends
report talking to the state uh
Performing Arts in 2023.
one thing that we did not discuss last
time was how you would kind of interact
with and organize this content so let's
focus on just a few things off the bat
first is the ability to filter
as we've added more content types to
positive Cloud it's getting it can get
quite complex what your content list
looks like because there's so many
things you could build so you can go
through here and filter right so if you
only wanted to look for that project
whether it was Jupiter notebook or our
studio IDE I can click on project and I
can see the 1R Studio project that I
have
I can go and look at applications
that I can find myself with the shiny
app and the streamlined app that I
mentioned
we've added more granularity to this as
well as the type of content that you can
now publish to positive cloud has really
grown both on the application side and
the document side as well
so you can you can filter that way you
can change by access so only show me
things that are publicly or are they
people that are in my space right now we
have no one in our space and actually if
I click on Space members uh only one of
them right now is designated to be seen
by anybody else
finally I can sort them either based
upon their name or their create date or
I can go ahead and I can search via text
and pull up and pick an attribution
model
so if you have very very long lists here
you know the search functionality the
filter functionality tends to help out
there is one more way that you can
interact and organize your data and
these are things called lists
so maybe we create a new list and we'll
call it deliverables
I have a choice do I want only admins to
see this or do I want everybody in
Allegro in this space and I'm going to
make it available for everybody because
ultimately I'm going to open this up for
potential clients
so once I have my list here if I click
on it you'll see that it's empty but you
can go back and just drag it everything
you want so you know maybe this document
was a deliverable uh the shiny
application itself the streamlit app
right so like these things that we
handed off to clients and this will be
the takeaways from the Consulting
engagement and if I click deliverables
now you're able to see this kind of list
that you put together on your own
um if you wanted to to do you know the
actual data projects maybe you wanted to
show somebody your coding ability for
the from the raw Source data or source
code we could make one called Data
projects I'll just drag over that ticket
attribution model into Data projects and
now I'm able to filter down at a much
more refined list than what you might
get from just standard filtering
so this in essence is how you can
organize a bunch of in information and
content within a space
now let's get to the point where we're
sharing this out with a client so you
could put together think of putting
together the proposal I'm really
interested in what you're looking to do
we have this experience here's a link
please join Myspace on posit cloud and
see everything that we can do and in an
interactive way right so let's make all
of these publicly or space member
available
last time we looked at this dot dot dot
on each piece of content if you click on
that and go to access you're going to be
able to see that you can change it from
private For Your Eyes Only uh to space
members I'm just going to do the same
thing for all four of these because we
want we want a potential client uh to
see all everything that we have to offer
in this space
so now we've put all this together and
we have these things that are able to be
shared out the problem is we don't have
a member within our space right now to
see these things
so we can click on the membership tab
and this is going to tell us who has
access to what and what is their role
within this space
so I'm going to click on
add members one way to do this I could
bring people in by email address but
this is going to be a pretty
generalizable space in the sense that we
might send this out to many potential
clients
so it probably is easier for us to use a
sharing link
and then we have to Define what role do
we want for this person who's going to
join this space to have
and if you click on the information
button here you can find out more about
admins and moderators and contributors
and viewers right now we only really
want people to be able to see what's in
this space so I'm going to go with this
viewer role
and I'm also going to ensure that down
at the bottom this this tab is unchecked
so when I do invite a viewer they cannot
view the membership space the membership
list unless someone is clicked this so
right now it'll be a pretty vanilla
space but they'll be able to see that
content that we want them to
so I'm going to copy this shared link
all right at the moment I'm going to
scroll down to see if any questions are
coming out on this specifically before
we jump over into the client account to
see how they would interact with that
app or that link that we just copied
and I don't see anything coming in right
now so let me switch over to a different
screen
good so I think now you can see my other
screen and this is going to be the
client so this is going to be Bartok
music festival and we had just given
them that link that we copied uh to
share this this portfolio space out with
it
when they click on this they're going to
have a path or a choice decision right
so you you're going to need for people
you share with to have a posit cloud
account and they can create a free
account that goes on to your to your
space
um in this case I already have one set
up on this machine and just a a free
Google account so I'm going to go ahead
and log in with with Google
and it should bring me back to the
invitation invitation page directly
so you can see that we've been asked to
join this space and because I trust a
link that came in from the person who is
applying uh or or making a proposal for
this Consulting gig I'm going to click
yes
and the first thing I'm going to see is
that introductory text that we put in
the about tab when we were acting on the
behalf of Allegro LLC so information
about why people are here maybe what the
next steps might be
um and then the potential client can
click on content
and all of those items that we made
available to our space members are now
available to this potential client
so if I click on this quarter doc
they were able to see now whatever
content we want to surface whatever
project we want to service for them to
get an understanding of the capabilities
of our Consulting team foreign
you might notice another thing compared
to the previous screen when we were
looking from uh the consultant's point
of view when we made this person a
viewer you know now there's no ability
to create a new project which is
probably good there's no ability to move
or copy or do anything with this pretty
much they're just getting a list of what
they can interact with what they can
engage with and then they can say you
know this is either going to help me
make a decision for hiring the specific
consultant or not
so let us take the optimistic approach
and say that the client was impressed
Enough by the portfolio that we put
together for them that they're going to
want to go ahead give the contract out
to Allegro LLC and we'll think of now
the second part of this demo which is
saying now I have a new client I have a
bunch of requirements that I need to
bring in in terms of where I'm going to
do work for them let's focus on that
stream next
so I'm going to go back into
posit cloud
see
there we go
okay so we're back into Allegro llc's
space that was the portfolio work but
now we're ready to go ahead and build up
an actual space for the work that's
going to be done and what's nice about
posit cloud is when you're creating
environments everything that you do
doesn't Cascade to all future projects
you're able to make these siled
reproducible environments that are
dedicated to one specific workflow
so to do this I'm going to go down to
the to the end of my list of spaces and
create a new space
and let's just call this Allegro
Bartok
I feel like we won't need to choose this
I have many accounts associated with
this this one account but it'll just be
tying back to the specific account that
you happen to own
then I'm going to create this new space
and now we have an increase and a
completely blank space that we can start
building up and we know that within this
space we want to be able to do the work
for the consultant and we know that we
also want to at the end of it be able to
bring the consultant in so we can do
some things to you know clean it up and
make it feel a little bit welcoming for
that client who will ultimately come uh
the first is we named it we included the
name of of the client's organization uh
just like before I can go to about and
maybe I drop in some information about
how you know we have data projects we
have outputs from this project we talk
about the date that the contract might
start when it might end and how long we
will keep this information within the
space before deleting it unless we hear
differently from the clients about what
we should do with the what the data sets
and the projects and the outputs that
might come from it
now depending on you know the nature of
this consulting company you might have a
project manager or a partner that are
going to go through after they win the
contract and then they're going to say
well we're going to bring in now an
analyst to this this team we're going to
bring in a data scientist
we could do that I don't want to go too
back and forth between too many screens
uh but yeah we could bring in members
and give them more advanced rights than
that viewership role right so I could
make them an admin or a moderator or a
contributor that would allow other
people from within my team to sort of do
meaningful work on behalf of this
clients
um but for the sake of this we're just
going to go ahead and get started by
doing work
um from this this one account this this
lead consultant approach
so we know that the consultant is going
to give us two things they're going to
give us one um some flat data files that
we're going to want to bring in to to a
project
but they also might give us like a
database credential
and from a shared space
I can actually go in here and say well
maybe the consultant is using postgres
so this could be a client
connection BB doesn't matter what we
call it and you know I would have a
bunch of information that I could fill
this Phil that's in here with
um and maybe it's a read-only connection
from their databases I could then go
ahead and save this connection
and I'm going to be able to pass this
connection through to all the other
projects and potentially the other
outputs that I'm going to eventually
deliver uh to the client we're not going
to get too much into Data connections at
some point we'll have a standalone
positive Cloud Essentials talking about
them directly but for now I just wanted
to say you know one way of information
one way of getting information from the
client into the projects for this
engagement would be through data
connections
but now I just want to go through and
create a new rstudio template
and maybe we call this dashboard prep
I mean one of the things that the client
wanted was looking at all their historic
data putting together a view of what
ticket sales and revenue has looked like
uh for the last several years we're
going to skip all of those those steps
but I want to show you what the flow
would look like
so now we've created an rstudio project
that sits within the Allegro Bartok
space dedicated to this client
engagement
and from here we can do you know what
you would expect to be able to do from
within within an IDE I'm going to go
ahead and make a new shiny app
because this is our first time in the
project it is like a blank canvas it's
up to you to fill it with the packages
you need the scripts you might want any
supplemental data you can bring in you
only need to do it one time and after
that you're going to be able when you
come back into the project you'll have
all these assets that are that are ready
for you
so maybe we'll just call this this
dashboard test for now
we created our a script and an app for
this shiny app and because posit cloud
is an integrated unified experience you
can go straight from doing the code
within positive Cloud to publishing
deposit cloud
so again I need to install a few more
packages this is going to give me what I
need to publish anywhere but to pause
the cloud specifically it facilitates
that as well
and now I can hit publish
for this sample app we should pop up in
roughly a minute
um you're going to you're you're going
to see that we can then publish it it
becomes an asset within the space and we
can decide who can see or who cannot see
the output
while you're waiting just another thing
to show as a reminder because we're up
in the cloud you know you're able to
change your memory allocated to this
project you're able to change your CPU
your background execution time you can
play with things like the name you can
add a description all these sort of
toggles you can do from the project
itself while keeping an eye on some of
those compute resources
and I can see now that the output the
shiny app is very close to publishing
it should open up a new tab for me and
I'm going to have to change the the
screen that I'm sharing on so let me
switch tabs very quickly here
yep and I see it on on our stream as
well so this is the interactive
application that the consultant just
made in theory right based upon the
information from our specific client
so very cool like we took just a few
steps we were able to create a project
publish another output if I go back to
my content list we can see that we have
these two things we have this app and we
have this project
now just because I want to tease a
little bit of a new feature that came
out two weeks ago which is called
project templates I want to show you how
you can turn this what you just did
right we went into that project we
installed different packages we created
a shiny app well imagine if you wanted
to have multiple projects Each of which
already having the same libraries maybe
the same data sets some of the same
starter applications for you to do more
work you can turn all that work you just
did into a template and then use that
customize template again and again when
creating new projects
and the way that you do it is simply to
do what we did we set up the environment
that we wanted
now I can click on settings
go into access
and I can say make this project a
template
as I clicked on make this project a
template you notice that this template
Banner or tag came up within our space
and if I click on this new item called
templates you'll see that this is the
one template that we currently have that
was made and created and is able to be
used from this Allegro Bartok shared
space
now if you wanted to use this template
to start a new project a little bit
faster
you then click on from new new project
the first time we selected a blank
rstudio project but if you want to do it
from template
now not only do you have a bunch of
pre-configured templates that posit has
put together for you to get started
faster you have the one that you created
specifically so if you use a lot of
custom templates or a lot of custom
scripts and you find yourself always
installing these again and again into
projects templates is a great way to get
started faster if you click OK this
would turn into just another project
that could be shared and that could
publish and be shared with others as
well
but for now we're not focusing on
templates today I'm going to turn this
off I'm not going to make this a
template anymore
it's going to disappear the template tag
will disappear and now we're left with
these two assets that we have and we
eventually want the client to take a
look at
so depending on the client you may or
may not want to share your source code
right so some want to see that others
might just want to see the application
let's go ahead and
take the assumption that all we're going
to share with the client is going to be
the final dashboard
let's come up with a really creative
name here call it final dashboard we can
add a description
all the ticket Trend data required for
this project
we've got a name we've got a description
I can then make this available to All
Space members
and now when I come back here we can see
that this dashboard has a little bit
more information it's available for all
space members and our project itself the
raw code is it has remained private
just like before we now want to find a
way to bring the the client into this
space to see their results so maybe you
have the final presentation with them
you know tomorrow or next week you want
them to have access to all this stuff
beforehand so when you're sitting down
you can go through it together
when we were thinking about the
portfolio gallery that was very generic
and there was nothing sensitive in there
to a specific client we just used a
sharing link uh which was a generic link
that anybody that came across could
actually use to get within your space
maybe for this we want to make an
invitation required and we're going to
go out through through email directly so
that we don't risk kind of putting out
one of those generic links that are out
there
um we still want to bring them in as a
viewer we don't want them to to see a
lot of the other bells and whistles we
just want them to hone in on that final
dashboard
so I'm going to bring them in as a
viewer
I guess it doesn't really matter if we
turn the the membership list on or off
for them I'll leave it on for now just
to show the difference
but what I want to do is take the email
address associated with that account
which I have I'm pasting in right now
I want to turn them into a viewer
and then I can send them a message to
join this space you know looking forward
to
our conversation tomorrow
here is the final dashboard
if I add it's going to come back and
verify that we sent an invitation
directly to that email address
and for the final time let me bounce to
the other screen where we're going to
look at
um what this looks like from the client
perspective
okay so we're starting now when this
comes up
we are in Gmail you can see the
invitation that was just sent to our uh
to our clients
the message that we put together we're
looking forward to our conversation
here's the final dashboard and now we're
sending that invitation to join that
space that we created
again they're going to be forced to to
log in through through their credentials
that they already have for posit Cloud
once they do that they should be able to
see the invitation or they accepted it
directly so so it went it went through
they're now within this space that are
lead consultant created
the lead consultant made a project and
an application all we can really see
here is that shiny app that we want them
to see
the the client can go in and see the
information we left about the about what
the space is and some of the details
about the project you can actually see
who else is it has access to this space
so maybe this again is something that's
good for Peace of Mind from the client
side you know how many people have
eyeballs on the analysis and outputs
from the project
and then finally the client can click on
this load it and interact with you know
the the advanced dashboard that we've
put together that ultimately would be uh
looking at uh the differences in ticket
sales
um over time for their uh Bartok Music
Festival
so I know we covered a lot of
information in that you know short trip
we were going back and forth between how
a data doer a data publisher might work
and then how somebody who's just viewing
especially in in terms of what a client
might expect from an engagement like
this
what I'd like to do now is pull up one
more tab
just to wrap up so we talk through these
two these two cases and we've started
with this notion of like seeing what can
be done within a space and I think a
combination of all of these when you add
an especially membership management
role-based permissions and then the
ability to tweak some of the specifics
over each one of those roles
and then one thing that we didn't look
at was the user analytics me as the
consultant being able to tie back you
know has this consultant has the client
viewed this information which assets
have they looked at how much have they
been using it works really well uh for
these workflows when you're doing maybe
a short-term project with a group of
people you want to maintain that
environment that is specifically guarded
for them and then at the end of that
whole sequence they've got you have the
ability to say well you know we can just
delete this space
um if that's what the the client has in
mind through the terms of of the
contract
so I think at that
point we're going to hand things over
for any q a that might can might have
come in Hannah is with me from posit and
I think she's going to help moderate
whatever might have come in
hey hey everyone hey Alex uh as Alex
mentioned I'm on the marketing team at
posit so I'm just going to help feed
some of the questions over that have
been coming through the chat just a
reminder if you still have questions
we're still taking them you can submit
them in the YouTube chat or using the
slido link that we shared earlier
so to start out we've got a couple of
questions that came in so first
one question is what are the pros and
cons compared to posit workbench and
posit connect
yeah that's a great question I know a
lot of the people were speaking with
recently have experience with those
self-hosted products so those for those
who do not know this is when you're
taking
um workbench and connect these are
things where you can author and publish
data science you're putting them on your
own servers you're maintaining those you
have full control and customization
um about what you can do in those in
those environments positive cloud is
really at this stage a subset of a lot
of that feature and functionality set
done in a purely SAS environment where
we take care of all of the
infrastructure it's a multi-tenant
solution so they're going to be
trade-offs on things like you know
complete control over uh security is one
one thing to to be aware of and also
some of our functionality at the moment
is not yet as advanced so if you think
of connect if you think of email a job
scheduling a report scheduling for
updates and emailing out we don't yet
have that functionality within positive
Cloud but over time we're going to be
adding and improving on both those
Dimensions the function reality set um
in the security set for those who are
able to operate in a cloud environment
we expect positive cloud is going to be
a pretty uh proficient place for you to
be doing so
awesome second question that came in was
does posit Cloud have Docker image
plug-in like workbench no at the moment
we do not have containerized support
and then Marlene asked most of this
navigation seems fairly intuitive how
long did it take you to get acclimated
that's a good question I actually
started using posit cloud in 2018 I
think in the early stages because I was
teaching a course on the side as a
part-time uh adjunct and it was very
easy to get set up in that case it was
very very simple in the education world
because our problem right was you'd
bring 30 40 people into a class and
you'd spend the entire class trying to
get everybody's tiny purse installed uh
in the same way trying to say well where
can I locate this file on my desktop so
giving people access to a specific state
of an environment for something like the
r Studio IDE or Jupiter notebook really
simplified that flow and I think it
works the same way on the data
professional side so if you have a team
of three or four people that are coming
in and they're sharing projects with
each other or they're putting outputs in
one space it simplifies all that and it
gives you some added continuity
um in terms of people coming on and off
your team to operate within those
environments I think finally like like
anything else you know when you start
when you start doing real work in a tool
you pick up you know what does work for
you and what doesn't work for you uh
well so you know I think if you've never
been in it and you're familiar with our
studio let's say you'll feel pretty
comfortable coding in our studio right
away and the bells and whistles around
it in terms of the management of either
people or capacity for compute you know
that'll take that'll take a little bit
of learning there is a comprehensive
guide that we can share a link to where
you can go through kind of read top to
bottom some of those elements that I
talked about today to get you up to
speed faster but I really think it takes
a few moments of failing uh before
you're going to get really comfortable
with the tool
so I know you covered a little bit about
templates but someone had asked are
there pre-built templates in posit Club
yeah let me go ahead and just switch my
screen
and then share that
which one do I want to do though
that works
yeah so this was added I believe
a week and a half ago maybe maybe two
weeks ago
um but if I get into back into posit
cloud
and I'm going to go to my workspace so
this is the the simple personal
workspace in this space you can't create
new ones
um new custom templates that you can
reuse but you can use the ones that
positive put together so if I click on
new project from template
you can see all of the available
templates that authors around posit have
put together and there's really two
purposes for this the first one is as we
saw in some of the examples today when
you start a new project from scratch you
need to install all of these packages to
get a lot of the work done that you're
going to get done and if you know
already you're just looking to do some
basic analysis uh with with pandas or on
the python side or with the tiny person
the r side you can click it you can know
what you need is going to be there so
like it speeds up that process for you
for kind of quick and dirty analysis
the other benefit to it is you might
notice from this screen if you're a
first time user it's a it's a pretty
blank environment right so we're giving
you the tools to do whatever you want
but it might be hard to know where to
start so what's great about the new
templating feature if I click on data
analysis and R of the Tidy verse and I
click ok
this is going to deploy the project for
me it's going to have a readme file
that's going to describe like what files
are already in here what sample data
might you have it's going to have all of
the libraries already configured and
pre-installed to support the the demo
files that that are in here so let's see
when this opens up
here we go you can see
we have a readme file which I'll talk
through a little bit about you know the
data set that's going to be used it's
going to talk through the files that are
already included but more impressively
when you click on languages
and this is a flow created by Sarah on
our team here you're going to see that
this is already calling in the library
it's going out to some specific data
included in this template and it's doing
basic you know exploratory analysis
if I change this to preview in the
viewer pane without me having to install
tidyverse without me having to install
anything related to quarto I should just
be able to render this
and it's going to take you know the 21
chunks that that are in the analysis
code and you can see right away we have
this uh this quarto HTML report that
goes out to that raw data uses tidy
verse functions to to sort of synthesize
it and and help you understand you know
the basics of data analysis so those two
purposes are what you can use it for to
speed up your workflows like you just
need tinyverse right now you don't feel
like creating your own custom template
click it start using it two for people
who maybe are not so familiar or don't
know where to get started or just want
to test you know the the feel and the
look of positive doing this type of work
in positive Cloud they can get in here
with some real data some real scripts
and start playing around
that's great
so we've got another question
um someone said it seems interesting but
I'm just wondering why use Jupiter
notebook via our posit how fast is it
compared to only using the Jupiter IDE
a I think it depends on where you're
doing your work right so if you're doing
Jupiter notebooks on your on your local
machine you know that's probably one way
to do it of course when you go that
route you need to set it up by yourself
you need to to get it to work what our
belief is is that over time people are
more inclined to work in these these
Cloud environments depending on the type
of work that they're doing right it's
not going to be for everyone in every
situation but I think the value
proposition is ultimately you're able to
log in to your web browser pull up a
variety of Ides right now it's just
rstudio ID and jupyter notebook but in
the future you know there likely will be
uh be more published things from that
work or from your desktop in deposit
cloud
and then use pause a cloud assist
environment that can really handle a
variety of different coding languages
that can host a variety of applications
and documents I think having it in that
unified space in an easy to use flexible
environment makes a lot of sense for a
lot of people
um so I think that like the three terms
we think of with posit Cloud are it is
convenient right you hop on you hop onto
your browser you log in you start doing
work it is simple everything is kind of
in this one unified environment you can
gate things into a space and have really
like containerized style work in that
environment like for the client that we
look through the workflow for today
um and the final is flexible so you know
this is a freemium product you can
experiment with a lot of this
functionality uh completely for free
we've added on new uh pricing models for
professionals this year at 25 a month
and 75 a month where you get different
specs and a different number of of
compute specs and different number of
compute hours associated with the plans
but a very simple environment to go
check out and see if this does work for
you to see if it is as performant
um and if not you know you turn it off
next month and there's no major
commitment on your end either
so the next two questions are similar
and they have to do with safety and
posit Cloud so someone asked how safe is
it in terms of data confidentiality and
protection and then the second related
question is how private safe is the data
on posit cloud
yeah great question and this is one of
the elements that we're going to look
into a lot more closely uh as we add
more functionality to the tool and we
expand into more kind of professional uh
use cases let me start by sharing a link
or I'll show the page first so it we've
added in the last two or three months a
new sub-page that talks about security
specifically
um we are doing all the architecture on
AWS we follow a certain set of best
practices uh related to to cloud
computing there so this page can talk
you through just what we do today on
authentication and encryption and
security how collaboration works and
what our application security looks like
so this is a starting point and the
reason that we put it up here is for
people who are evaluating the tool to
say is this sufficient for my needs
right we talk to people in in finance in
Pharmaceuticals quite a lot for a lot of
their work right now you know these
security specs don't match their needs
for what they're doing in terms of you
know legally what they're able to do
within a tool for others it is
completely it is completely valid way
for them to conduct their analysis in
one unified space where they're able to
get people from around their
organization to start contributing
I will say that as we are going to start
paying even more attention to our
security uh footprint uh we're going to
be working through something called the
cloud control Matrix which will
hopefully put us in line uh to get some
of those additional badges that you
might hear on the security front and we
think that each wave of iteration on the
security front will bring in a wider
array of organizations who are able to
technically uh legally
um uh to to get into positive cloud and
start doing their work there
awesome
the last question that I see right now
and you may have mentioned this but does
posit Cloud support vs code
also a great question and that's one of
the that's one of the features that you
would find in workbench right where you
can have Jupiter lab or vs code or
Jupiter notebook
the moment posit Cloud does not
we are definitely planning on our
roadmap is bringing in some of these
more sophisticated python tools to make
that experience you know more balanced
between our coders and python coders
awesome
well I think that might be all of the
questions that we're gonna have today so
thank you Alex and thank you everyone
for tuning in today submitting your
questions I'll just make a note that
we're hosting these events every month
on the last Tuesday of the month so next
month we'll have another pause at Cloud
Essentials event
um you can view all of these past events
on YouTube within a playlist uh that is
linked in the description section of
this event also you can add the upcoming
events to your calendar using a link in
the description of this YouTube event so
thank you Alex thank you all for joining
and we'll see you next month thanks
everyone thanks Hannah thanks